[Music]
I'm going to the car they flashed me a
card that said go to the go to the why
that is the interview going that no no
it's going
great it's going great Pete go to the
card I ask question 12 it is question 12
it just says Franklin and Bash oh yeah
because we have to talk about
that okay we
did remember when you wrote a theme song
for Bayside and and then you were
getting too cocky so they gave you lemon
juice and you couldn't
sing that's so funny because honestly
when I when I hear that I go that sounds
like a great show
that like that's a really cool thing
like I was I'd kind of want to watch
that show it was the Breaking Bad of its
time C pills
meth